de rejoindre mon collègue philippe
folliot sur ses réflexions effectivement
vos propos liminaire en tout cas mon
enrichi
par rapport à ce que je savais puisque
lorsque j'étais maire de cayenne j'ai eu
l'occasion très souvent de discuter avec
madame chantal maurice qui est
directrice régionale d'orange notamment
sur le câble kanawa et franchement je
vous en remercie j'apprécie en tout cas
beaucoup vous interventions et c'est
vrai que sans cet outil moderne je ne
sais pas comment les collectivités
locales les citoyens et les
administrations pourraient se passer de
cet outil moderne et c'est vrai comme
l'a rappelé philippe tout à l'heure il
ya quand même des dysfonctionnements des
déséquilibres en tout cas en guyane sur
tout ce qui concerne le numérique en
tout cas merci beaucoup bon les câbles
sous-marins peuvent-ils améliorer
concrètement le développement économique
et l'intégration des collectivités et
territoires d'outre-mer dans leurs
bassins océaniques respectives je le
répète ans je pense qu'on a dans la
caraïbe un rôle à jouer et on a le
levier de l'autre qui peut nous aider à
être véritablement que ce soit au niveau
de la partie insulaire de la caraïbe ou
au niveau terrestre autour de la guyane
quand on voit la mapaq est isolé du
reste du brésil par exemple on sait très
bien que cette région de la mapa elle
est plus tourné potentiellement vers la
guyane française d'un plateau des
guyanes que vers on va dire brésilien
est donc on voit bien que c'est pareil
le surinam et s'éteint donc on voit bien
qu'on a dans ses bassins des véritables
opportunités d'être des zones
d'attractivité des zones de
développement et pas subi on va dire
parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait très bien
que saint laurent du maroni est là et la
future capitale des territoires
ultramarins
puisque la toute croissance de la
population à saint-laurent-du-maroni
dépasse toute forme de toute croissance
français y compris mayotte qui est battu
à plate couture donc en fait on va avoir
là une ville sera plus grosses que ça la
réunion en 2050 pour qu'un câble sous
marin et une efficacité à la fois
opérationnelles et économique il faut
que ce besoin de connectivité existe
j'aurais rappelé que en ce qui concerne
par exemple la métropole 80% du trafic
qui est générée par les internautes
français est à destination d'une façon
ou d'une autre des états unis pourquoi
puisque comme l'a rappelé stéphane lelux
les données les applications les
services auxquels souhaitent accéder les
internautes français et bien sont
localisées de façon extrêmement
majoritaire
aux états unis et cette réalité elle
s'applique également aux outre mer on a
évoqué par exemple le cas des caraïbes
80% du trafic est généré par les
internautes guyanais est à destination
des états unis 20 % seulement sont à
destination de la métropole il faut donc
se garder des idées simplistes qui
dirait qu un moyen efficace de renforcer
la compétitivité économique de la guyane
serait d'augmenter les nombres de câble
sous marin entre la guyane et le
territoire métropolitain
c'est un non sens